Speaker 1: Let's speak to a few more people.
David Pakman dot com slash discord is the
place to do it. Let's go to Sammy in
New York City. Sammy, what's going on?
Sammy in New York City, please unmute
yourself. You have self muted and that
is why no one can hear you. You are on
the air. But you have muted yourself,
Sammy. And if you unmute yourself. Yes.
Speaker 2: Can you hear me? Yes. Oh,
my God. Finally I got through. David, quick
question. And you might have already answered
this and another podcast. And I love your show, by
the way. Thank you. If. Mike Pence had said it had
agreed with Donald Trump and said, hey, you know
what, I am going to stop the election of Biden.
What would have. What would that process have
been like? I mean, I know he couldn't, but like,
he's like, okay, yeah, I'm going to do it. Yeah.
Speaker 1: This is a very good question.
I can't say that. I can tell you for certain
exactly what the sequence would have been if
Pence did try to stop the election from being
certified right. I don't believe he ultimately
would have succeeded, but I think it would have
been very dangerous and it probably would have
been something like Pence would say in certain
states, like when they get to Arizona saying we
give our votes to Biden. Pence would have
said something like, you know, due to the
controversy outstanding. And Bubba ba ba, ba ba,
I am not going to accept those electoral votes.
If he wanted to go further, he could have said,
I'm going to recognize an alternate slate of
electors. And that would have probably become
a constitutional crisis if he simply rejected
to accept some. My understanding is that it just
lowers the total number and it lowers the number
you need to be president from 270 to something
lower and by probably still becomes president,
but with fewer. But the point is, it would
have been extremely dangerous and it would
have been a perilous moment for our democracy.
Speaker 2: Right. Obviously, he couldn't have
carried it out any way by agreeing he's been such
a Trump like of his the whole while. So I'm just
was curious about that. And David, I'm so excited
to talk to you like I watch you every day. Well,
thank you. Oh, amazing. I appreciate it. Yes,
absolutely. And good luck to your family.
And I am I'm just blown away at how amazingly
informative you are. I love and appreciate that.
Speaker 1: I'm sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube channel.
Speaker 2: I 1,000% media.
Speaker 1: Bureau. I knew that
feeling. Sammy, that you are.
Speaker 2: I am. All right.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much
for the call. I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: My pleasure. Have a good day.
Speaker 1: Sammy from the city. Great, great stuff